Blue holes are normally
found on reefs.
Yet this wouldn't be the
first time a chasm has
opened up close to
Australia's east coast.
In September 2015, a
giant hole appears
overnight at a campsite
on Inskip Point,
swallowing a 1000 foot
long section of
coastline, cars and
caravans.
A fear made all the more
real by a recent
scientific expedition
close to the Great
Barrier Reef.
Researchers have recently
discovered an area where
part of the reef is
actually breaking away
and is perched above a
deep underwater canyon.
The giant disintegrating
slab is one and a half
miles long.
It's only a matter of
time that this will
eventually tumble down
and will create a tsunami
that could be absolutely
catastrophic.